the solar system appears to be a
perfectly tuned mechanism when viewed at
large
by contrast there's a real realm of
chaos between the orbits of mars and
jupiter
this is where hundreds of thousands of
small celestial objects whizz around
space in all sorts of directions
occasionally crossing other objects
orbits they sometimes get in each
other's way and produce thousands of
shards and bits on collision
with this area of space highly
changeable
it is hardly possible to predict what it
will look like in the distant future
[Music]
of course we'll be talking about the
main asteroid belt one of the most
changeable and mysterious areas in the
solar system
today over 300 000 small celestial
bodies found here have been given names
and numerical designations interestingly
their overall number may well reach over
a million
the starting point of studying the
asteroid belt may be defined at 1801
when astronomers spotted a mysterious
object in the sky after a long and hard
search for the fifth planet
in terms of its parameters it appeared
to be a planet but happened to be so
small that even the most advanced
telescopes of the day couldn't
distinguish its disk the researchers saw
the newly discovered object as a bright
dot like a star
it was dubbed series and very soon
similar celestial objects of this class
were discovered a new term had to be
introduced to refer to them these
unusual astronomical bodies came to be
called asteroids which literally means
star-like
apart from asteroids this area in the
solar system contains great amounts of
cosmic dust while slowly spiraling up
its tiny particles scatter sun rays and
create a very faint white glow
this glow is referred to as zodiacal
light
interestingly in equatorial areas of the
earth it can be seen with a naked eye
for a long time the following hypothesis
used to be widely accepted asteroid belt
objects were thought to be debris of a
destroyed planet
however today this assumption doesn't
really hold water
first of all the mass total of all the
objects of the main asteroid belt is too
small and equals just 3 times 10 to the
power of 21 kilograms
or 4 percent the mass of the moon even
allowing for the fact that the greater
part of asteroids would have left about
a while ago the total mass of the rocky
debris still falls short of making up an
object with dimensions comparable to
those of a proper planet
secondly estimates show that large
celestial objects cannot form in this
area of the solar system on account of
jupiter's gravitational influence
mathematical modelling revealed that the
largest formations in the asteroid belt
have never measured over a thousand
kilometers in diameter the gravitational
influence of their mighty giant neighbor
rendered their orbits highly unstable
which made potential protoplanets
collide and disintegrate into smaller
bits
traces of these collisions can still be
observed
most objects of the main belt group
together to form the so-called asteroid
families populations of asteroids of
similar makeup and of the same origin it
is thought that they formed as a result
of such destructive collisions
the borders of the main asteroid belt
are rather blurred
most of the objects making it up lie
within 2.06 to 3.27 astronomical units
from the sun
these boundaries are predefined by
jupiter's tidal forces and are referred
to as kirkwood gaps
any celestial objects getting into these
zones experience the massive gas giant's
strong gravitational influence which
destabilizes their orbits this is the
reason why the space object count here
is considerably lower than beyond
kirkwood gaps can be found not only on
the conventional borders of the belt but
inside it too
two of the most clearly defined gaps lie
2.5 and 2.82 astronomical units away
from the sun the asteroid belt is also
conventionally divided into two large
areas inner and out about
the border between them is a kirkwood
gap with a radius measuring 2.5
astronomical units which coincides with
the highest orbital resonance with
jupiter it's in the outer part of the
main belt that the largest object in
this area of the solar system is
situated
ceres
this celestial object used to be thought
a planet then an asteroid but eventually
in 2006 it was given the status of a
dwarf planet it was possible to do so
thanks to the fact that ceres has a
spherical shape unlike the absolute
majority of the other objects and
its diameter measures around
940 kilometers and its mass 9.4 times 10
to the power of 20 kilograms which
incidentally accounts for around a third
of the overall mass of the asteroid belt
this makes series approximately 6 000
times lighter than our planet
the furthest point of the dwarf planet's
orbit from the sun is 2.9 astronomical
units
when ceres is at its perihelion the
distance to our system's center measures
around two and a half astronomical units
at this point the planetoid surface
temperature may reach
239 kelvin or 33 degrees celsius below
zero although its average temperature is
noticeably smaller
at just
167 kelvin
or 106 degrees celsius below zero
the celestial body is thought to be made
up of a rocky core enveloped in a cryo
mantle around a hundred kilometers thick
water ice accounts for up to half of the
dwarf planet's volume or twenty to
thirty percent of its mass
the inner part of the belt harbors the
largest and most massive known asteroid
in the solar system
vesta
the object's average diameter measures
roughly
525 kilometers
and its mass is around 2.6 times 10 to
the power of 20 kilograms which is
almost four times as little as that of
ceres the asteroids orbit is rather
elongated with its ophelian 2.57
astronomical units and its perihelion
around 2.15 astronomical units away it
takes the celestial body 3.6 earth years
to complete a full orbit around the sun
vesta is also remarkable for being the
only asteroid visible to the naked eye
it can be seen not only on account of
its impressive dimensions but also
thanks to its comparatively light
surface that reflects about 42 percent
of light shed on it
besides the minimal distance between
vesta and the earth isn't that great at
just
177 million kilometers or 1.18
astronomical units
it is assumed that wester is a fully
fledged planet in terms of its inner
makeup
it appears to have a metallic core made
up of nickel and iron as well as a rocky
mantle the surface temperature of the
asteroid is currently fluctuating
between
-190 and minus 20 degrees celsius
but it used to be much warmer in the
past
dark areas to be seen on the surface in
the western hemisphere are highly likely
to be basalt plains such terrain
features may have formed as a result of
volcanic activity or collision events
with massive astronomical bodies the
most outstanding geological feature on
the asteroid is the giant impact crater
referred to as rear silvia whose
diameter measures up to 500 kilometers
and its depth is around 25 000 meters
the second largest mountain in the solar
system is situated at its center
towering higher than 22 kilometers
impressively the crater's diameter
almost equals vesta's size it looks like
the asteroid collided with a really
large object at some point in the past
the collision would have produced not
only the rear silvia crater but also a
great number of small bits which are now
classified as the family of wester's
numerous asteroids
the family counts over fifteen thousand
objects making up around five percent of
all celestial bodies of the main belt
known to science today
it is posited that most asteroid
families came to be as a result of
destructive collisions of two large
celestial objects
sometimes the debris are mutually
attracted by gravity forces which
usually blend them into a new
astronomical object
however it would have lost its
monolithic nature
and sometimes astronomers informally
call such formations rubble piles for
example sylvia one of the largest
objects in the asteroid belt seems to
fall into this category of celestial
bodies
its parameters are
384 by 262
by
232 kilometers with a mass 1.5 times 10
to the power of 19 kilograms
this makes the asteroid's average
density just 20 percent higher than that
of water
estimates show that cavities may account
for 25 to 60 percent of its volume
it takes sylvia 6.5 years to complete a
full orbit around the sun
the object's orbit's furthest point from
the center of the system is up to 3.7
astronomical units in its perihelion
sylvia gets as close to the sun as 3.2
astronomical units
it is assumed that some bits of debris
left after a collision are not attracted
to other bits but rather become
satellites of the new celestial body
sylvia is known to have two such
companions
romulus with a diameter measuring 18
kilometers and remus measuring around
seven kilometers
their makeup hasn't been studied yet and
it is highly likely that these objects
are not monolithic either
besides silvia may theoretically have
smaller satellites as well which haven't
been detected yet
palace is another remarkable object in
the asteroid belt it was discovered back
in 1802 right after series
and is the second largest asteroid in
the bout the average diameter of the
celestial body is around 512 kilometers
and its mass is roughly 2 times 10 to
the power of 20 kilograms which is
approximately 25 percent less than that
of vesta
the asteroid's orbit is exceptionally
elongated and tilts to the ecliptic
plane at 35 degrees
that is the reason why the astronomical
body is so hard to investigate with
probes as for its orbital period it
takes palace around 4.6 years to orbit
the sun in the course of which the
distance to the system center changes
more than one and a half times with its
perihelion 2.1 astronomical units its
aphelion is 3.4 astronomical units away
palace's surface is widely pockmarked
with craters
much more so than the largest series of
vesta studies of the chemical
composition of the asteroid's surface
reveal that it mostly consists of
silicate rocks with small amounts of
iron and water just like vesta this
celestial body is thought to be one of
the few potential protoplanets that are
still around which means that studying
it may yield important information about
the formation process of the solar
system
unlike vesta most asteroids cannot be
seen either with the naked eye or
through amateur telescopes
one of these elusive objects is called
interrumnia
admittedly one of the most mysterious
objects of the main asteroid belt
this is an irregular shaped asteroid
with parameters 306
by 348 by 310 kilometers
and its mass accounts for roughly 1.2
percent of the overall mass of all
objects and the bout in spite of its
relatively large size however interamlia
remains largely understudied
one of the difficulties thwarting
scientific progress here is the
asteroid's dark surface which absorbs
around 93 percent of light shed on it
interamnia falls into the exceptionally
rare spectral class f which is a
subclass of carbonaceous asteroids
research of its reflection shows that
the color of the celestial body's
surface is even which means that inter
amnio hasn't experienced big collisions
for quite a long time
inter amnious density is not that great
at just twice that of water
the asteroid is thought to be made up of
a hard rocky core enveloped in a thick
layer of ice the surface is covered with
great amounts of fine dark dust
it takes centuramnia around five years
and four months to complete a full orbit
around the sun
itsophilia is on the opposite side from
four largest objects of the main bout
and the distance from the asteroid to
the sun varies from 2.5 to 3.5
astronomical units
in theory interramania's orbit crosses
the trajectories of such large objects
as series and palace but estimates show
that chances of their colliding with
each other are small
there are millions of objects in the
main belt from dwarf planets to tiny
meteoroids the size of a cobblestone
however distances between them measure
thousands upon thousands or even
millions of kilometers
that is why spacecraft crossing the belt
would be running an almost negligible
risk of getting hit by any astronomical
body
still mathematical modelling shows that
around once every 10 million years some
remarkable collisions take place in this
part of the solar system that produce
new debris
even though a manned mission to
asteroids in the main belt will not be
in the pipeline for a long while
some of the asteroids there have been
studied with the help of interplanetary
space probes for example the dawn probe
carried out observations of ceres
investor in the period from 2011 to
2016.
quite recently the space probe lucy
blasted off the surface of the earth
even though its main goal is the
so-called jupiter trojans the spacecraft
will approach the object known as donald
johansen in the main belt and take its
pictures in 2025.
also the launch of the psyche project is
scheduled for july 2022
with the largest known metallic asteroid
of the main belt as its target
within the mission the probe is planned
to reach its destination by early 2026
and remain in the asteroid belt for at
least 21 months while studying the
asteroids terrain makeup and magnetic
field
small though they may be asteroids are
important both from the scientific and
practical point of view
some main belt objects are real treasure
troves dating back to the early stages
of the solar system formation studying
them will give us clearer insights into
processes of how planets and other
celestial bodies form
and in the future asteroids will make
sources of materials for space
exploration
we don't know when we will be ready for
this
but every new rocket launched into space
brings the space era slightly closer
and every new like you give us brings a
nice new video closer
let's keep in touch
you